[Música]
[Aplausos]
wow cuánta energía realmente estoy algo
nervioso así que me espero que por favor
me disculpen mi nombre es javier garcía
blázquez soy ingeniero industrial de
formación pero soy un apasionado para lo
que es la innovación social los
conocimientos los temas duros son muy
importantes sin embargo no vengo
precisamente a hablar de ello sino más
bien vengo a conversar sobre algo que de
pronto es más importante o tan cual
importante que son los procesos todo ese
camino toda esa ruta que nosotros
seguimos para que se logren diferentes
cosas vamos a tratar de conversar hoy
día sobre lo que se desarrolla un día a
la vez
pero para ello yo soy profe y necesito
que ustedes me respondan algunas cosas
para sentirme más cómodo y no sentirme
observado
por favor en una palabra y directo qué
cosa entienden ustedes por emprendedor
el que hace las cosas
creativo apasionado e iniciativa
arriesgado excelente gracias me están
dando un poco más de severidad
un emprendedor como ustedes muy bien
están diciendo es alguien que se lanza a
la piscina alguien que se arriesga
alguien que ante una oportunidad de
negocio ante una oportunidad se lanza a
ella para poder lograr algo distinto es
alguien que lucha y que se apuesta por
ello un emprendedor es aquella persona
ahora hay una pequeña diferencia con el
otro concepto que deseo que ustedes
manejen que es el emprendedor social
alguien acá me podría decir así como me
dijeron respecto a lo que es un
emprendedor qué cosa es un emprendedor
social
y han hablado de propósito para qué
perfecto y por aquí
generó un impacto estamos hablando ahora
de otro tipo de temas que son sumamente
importantes y parecen realmente valiosos
perfecto y todo lo que ustedes están
diciendo es algo sumamente importante y
obviamente relevante un emprendedor
social es aquel que busca un impacto es
aquel que busca algo que está ocurriendo
y que se está generando pues un problema
que quiere cambiar esa realidad alguien
que se indigna de algo que ocurre
alguien que de pronto se lanza a la
misma piscina y el anterior pero para
poder lograr buscar un mundo mejor
ese es el emprendedor social
pero yo ahora lo que quiero compartir
con ustedes son algunas pequeñas
historias como para que puedan entender
un poco más ligado a este tema
al paso del emprendedor paso del
emprendedor social rápidamente y vamos a
irnos a la siguiente que es esta
historia
jóvenes que como ustedes personas que
como ustedes quieren transformar la
realidad ricardo rodriguez joven piurano
que cuando joven el sufrió junto a su
tío platero los terribles problemas
ligados a la a los problemas que te
genera un mundo que no es
suficientemente inclusivo para personas
con discapacidad
su tío tenía discapacidad física y él le
prometió a su tío que iba a convertir
ese mundo en un mundo mejor para él
lamentablemente su tío se fue pero él
quedó con esa deuda hoy en día
riccardo luchando contra la adversidad
día a día un día a la vez pivoteando su
idea cambiando su modelo de negocio
tiene un emprendimiento que se llama
pick set y que en base a las impresiones
3d produce piezas ortopédicas que
permiten generar un mundo mucho más
inclusivo para personas con discapacidad
discapacidad física ricardo rodríguez
acuérdense de ese nombre
así como ricardo tenemos otro caso que
es sumamente interesante ella en esa
unión una joven hija de padres
trujillanos que cuando niña como muchos
de ustedes su abuelita le leía cuentos
antes de dormir
tóbal y tote leía algo antes de dormir
aquí hay una historia y también contigo
estás enfatizando piensa fundamental
para ello pues bien todo hermoso hasta
que interesa empezó a crecer y como niña
un día cuando ya había aprendió a leer
se dio cuenta que su abuelita le leía
los cuentos al revés
de paso su abuelita tal cual como muchas
mujeres de nuestro país era analfabeta
ella sintió una terrible frustración
ante ello porque sencillamente no
concebía como alguien que leía cuentos
tan hermosos no supiese leer y eso fue
lo que gatilló en ella y de joven empezó
a desarrollar un emprendimiento de alto
impacto social un millón de niños
lectores un emprendimiento que busca
cambiar la realidad de personas que no
tienen acceso a la lectura mediante el
desarrollo de bibliotecas públicas
theresa gullón tuvo que pivotará varias
veces tuvo que hacer muchos esfuerzos y
al final están logrando
ss pero ese gran objetivo que tiene
ligado a la educación pues bien tenemos
otra historia más y la historia que
viene es de una joven
cynthia en donde ella desde muy niña
vivía o vivía con victoria con su
hermana y su hermana es una joven
extraordinaria un atleta de deportes es
competidora nacional que tiene síndrome
de down ella al igual que su hermana
fueron tratadas y fueron acompañadas por
su madre de una manera muy similar su
madre una persona con una mentalidad muy
muy abierta y altamente comprensiva
colaboró y apoyo en el desarrollo
emocional de ambas sin embargo sintió
cuando creció se dio cuenta que este
mundo no era un mundo inclusivo para
personas con discapacidad cognitiva qué
cosa es lo que desarrolló desarrolló un
modelo de negocio pero ojo ese modelo de
negocio no se basa en la tristeza su
modelo de negocio se llama en pana combi
una empanada o venden empanadas que son
deliciosas
y cuál es el extra que tiene ese modelo
de negocio que el 50 por ciento de
personas que trabajan en esa empresa son
personas que tienen algún tipo de
discapacidad ok entonces estos tres
jóvenes son tres historias
extraordinarias que han incorporado la
innovación para un proceso de trabajo
que a mi criterio es único que es
sumamente valioso ya mencionaba una
palabrita interesante que es la de
innovación pero antes y yo quiero
explorar algo porque de pronto no se los
comenté yo deambuló por muchas regiones
de nuestro país y conversó con jóvenes
como ustedes sobre lo que sienten que
ocurre en nuestro país y les hago una
siguiente pregunta
el peruano es creativo
vale vale vale si en efecto somos muy
creativos y tengo la siguiente pregunta
y espero que me la respondas con
absoluta transparencia y seguridad el
peruano que es más es más innovador o
recurso
de repente ni siquiera sabes que el
recurso pero de pronto le antepone sello
vamos a probar esto si hubiese una
mesita acá una mesita que usted me ha
hecho le quita qué cosas es
un papel una chapita y siempre pero cada
uno es lo que quiera lo que pregunta
cuánto tiempo se queda con eso
señales esa es nuestra gran capacidad de
ser apaga incendios tenemos tanta
habilidad para solucionar en una los
problemas que de pronto no innovamos no
damos un paso más allá no creamos valor
porque solucionamos los problemas de
manera inmediata a veces invirtiendo el
menor esfuerzo y eso genera sus
problemas porque acá para cerrar esta
pequeña introducción quiero reforzar que
la innovación es algo más que
simplemente creatividad es la unión de
tres elementos poderosos que sí tienen
la creatividad promedio por supuesto
pero tiene también el momento exacto en
donde lo vas a ejecutar y ojo tienes la
oportunidad donde todo tu estudio de
investigación las veces que te caes al
suelo haciendo algo
van a generar que puedas lograr una gran
meta
señores lamento decirles que esa idea
milenaria mañana no se va a convertir en
la empresa más grande del mundo tienes
que sufrir es que caminar un poco tienes
que vivir el proceso
un día a la vez y más de una oportunidad
tendrás que pivotear y esta palabra le
ha repetido varias veces se entiende lo
que quiero tener
y los veo muy seguros pero no quiero
hacer la pregunta quiero mostrarles esto
que se observa
no te rías que se observa un problema
verdad un problema un carro está nadando
y hay una grúa que no está rescatando un
problema y tu solución planteada
perfecto que te puede pasar en la vida
de pronto ya está solucionando el
problema estamos excelente problema y tu
estrategia de solución
y
qué pasará
uy
porque te burlas
bert ojo tu puedes sacar un
emprendimiento adelante puedes hacer
todo tu análisis pero las cosas pueden
fallar porque es así pueden fallar pues
bien tú tienes que resiliente quieres
volver a empezar darte cuenta de lo que
has hecho y volver a empezar
de pronto volviste a empezar y te pudo
pasar esto mira trajiste un nuevo
tractor una nueva grúa y volvió a traer
señores
en la vida tú puedes tropezar más de una
vez aunque por ahí dicen que el ser
humano es la única criatura que tropieza
con la misma piedra más de una vez bueno
el problema no ha cambiado de pronto
ahora tienes más carritos que están
nadando
era el momento
traer una curva más grande
de pronto d'hebron de esa no es la
solución yo sé que tu pensamiento algo
morboso está esperando a ver la
siguiente imagen donde también se caiga
la mente informarte que no hay una
siguiente imagen lo que quiero lo que
quiero reflexionar ahora es que nosotros
independientemente del emprendimiento la
empresa y lo que nosotros hagamos
podemos tener muchos tropiezos pero
tenemos que ser suficiente mismo
intención para pivotear es decir cambiar
la estrategia y la estrategia que todos
estamos planteando no funciona pues
debemos plantear otra estrategia porque
porque nosotros nos tenemos que enamorar
no de la solución sino del problema y
ese problema es el elemento que nos va a
gatillar para poder realmente encontrar
la mejor estrategia que tú buscas así
como ricardo rodríguez de pick set tenía
un serio problema que era generar un
mundo más inclusivo y desarrollo mil
estructuras de ideas para lograrlo así
como teresa muñoz que tenía un problema
de
de esa indignación que le provocaba el
hecho de que la gente sea analfabeta y
que no hayan lugares como bibliotecas
públicas para leer así como cynthia
sentía coraje porque el mundo no era
suficientemente inclusivo para que
personas con discapacidad cognitiva
puedan tener un espacio laboral digno
tú puedes pivotear y debe voltear pero
ojo
el bigote o no es algo exclusivo para la
empresa y para el emprendimiento
así como las estrategias no son
exclusivas
para estos modelos
también para tu vida
corría el año 2014 vivía yo más de 10
años de casados matrimonio perfecto
hijos todo aparentemente bien un bonito
trabajo mi esposa también cada uno
avanzaba evolución nada se desarrollaba
iba consiguiendo cosas
aparentemente éramos felices
hasta que un día
ella se me acercó y me dijo
normalmente me dice javi me dijo javier
tenemos que hablar
les han dicho tenemos que hablar alguna
vez
es mejores y game over
a jalar los cables apagar la luz en ese
momento el mundo se me volteo en ese
momento yo no sabía que pasar me
entendía que había hecho mal que parte
de la tarea no la había estructurado de
manera adecuada yo era un buen esposo
creía estaba haciendo las cosas
aparentemente bien creía y ella me hizo
ver que efectivamente éramos buenas
personas pero cada uno estaba caminando
en una dirección distinta nuestra
sociedad
con tal como si fuese una sociedad de
emprendedores se estaba separando y cada
uno caminaba por otro lado
estuve en ese momento porque fue un
gatillo muy intenso
y le dije
en ese momento adquirieron muchas ideas
era una de ellas patear el tablero que
lo más fácil pero le dije tratemos de
hacer algo tratemos de luchar por
nuestro matrimonio es el primero que se
me ocurrió y nos sumergimos a ello
empezamos día a día a luchar lo
planteamos estrategias un día me dijo
javier han pasado meses esta granada
pongamos un decline como le vas a poner
un decline a ver si sigues enamorado no
y seguíamos tras esta estrategia
haciendo lo mismo lo mismo y lo mismo y
lo mismo
un momento en que estaba algo fatigado
se veía una luz al final del túnel la
verdad que no sabía si es que era la
salida o un tren que venía en contra
pero en ese momento
algo nos hizo gatillar porque ya estamos
exhaustos y nos dimos cuenta que la
estrategia que habíamos estado
trabajando para poder hacer que el
concepto matrimonio sea inmortal en el
tiempo era algo que precisamente nos
estaba desgastando y empezamos a pensar
que la construcción de una sociedad
cualquiera que fuese exitosa se
construye un día a la vez tú no puedes
construirlo todo en un instante y tener
la seguridad de que va a ser felices por
siempre como los cuentos de hadas porque
te dicen feliz y por siempre pero no te
cuentan lo que ocurre el día siguiente
del felices por siempre
y un día a la vez como un factor
interesante porque también íbamos al
psicólogo el hecho de ver la cuenta de
lo que se pagaba el psicólogo también
nos hizo reflexionar
y un día a la vez empezamos a
construirlo empezamos a construir la
felicidad un día a la vez para concluir
quiero cerrar esto porque la innovación
y el emprendimiento social conecta
corazones somos humanos y el pivoteo y
el cambio estrategias las podemos llevar
a cualquier ámbito de nuestra vida no te
concentres en una vida de sufrimiento
sino concéntrate en un poderoso proceso
de desarrollo y haz que éste sea de
excelencia un día a la vez muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]